so in early May redbull kicked off its
2v2 redbull flick tournament circuit
it's meant to be full of crazy
highlights and aim battles with a mix of
amateurs and csgo pros dueling it out
for 20,000 euros but in the finals of
the finished circuit two players were
caught cheating by the community and
face it has since banned them from
competing so let's break down what the
hell happened
[Music]
okay so by now you might have noticed
that score eSports is streaming over on
Twitch we've done a couple stop our
squads stream seeds with some r6 pros
and even gone live with our talk show
clouded so if you haven't already head
over to twitch TV slash to score eSports
follow the channel and hit that
notification button so you know when we
go live and maybe just maybe you'll
catch me slamming my desk
alright let's get back to the story so
the finals for the finish portion of the
red bull flicks series happened on May
23rd part of the finals was a show match
between Anza zmp and a Luo and two dudes
named molds and Jay Z now because they
won the finish
tournament both wolves and Jays a were
scheduled to move on to the EU closed
qualifiers finals with 20,000 euros on
them and while the competition was
serious I mean there was roughly the
equivalent of twenty-two thousand USD up
for grabs
it was really an excuse to watch
high-level players pull off some clip
worthy nonsense that wouldn't fly during
the major now it's your chance to prove
you are the next greatest duo and play
against the very best in redbull click
the new 2v2 csgo competition on face it
but these two randoms actually beat
ences best that isn't safe but the
internet immediately called [ __ ]
with cheating allegations popping up all
over ready bomb gone again
Bosley embarass Kavala Thommo Thommo
Lima Bella boys and the shouting from
reddit actually caused face it who
partnered with red bull for the event to
open up an investigation into these
allegations quote turn the red bull
flick Finland National Finals several
members of the community began to share
information about a potential case of
cheating involving the players Wald's
and Jezza end quote and then on
Wednesday red bull and face it announced
that after looking into the situation
they were straight-up banning both
wolves and jay-z for cheating now the
two accounts belong to Wald's and Jays a
were a part of a larger group of
accounts banned by face it's anti cheat
system now according to face it the
reason why both players weren't banned
immediately is that there was a
technical issue with their anti cheat
system that they managed to fix on
Wednesday and then after looking into
the situation red bull and face it
announced that both players would be
disqualified from the event but the
thing is we don't officially know what
they did and we
also don't know if they cheated in other
games during this tournament a lot of
people online have been speculating that
it was because they used some sort of
game tracking software but face it
doesn't say specifically what happened
these guys managed to make it to the
finals of a show match against
professional csgo players with a shot at
20,000 euros on the line they decided to
cheat and despite us not knowing
officially what happened it was enough
for face it to basically go hey YouTube
get the [ __ ] out and ironically they
cheated against EMP you know that kid
with a vac band account associated with
his name we did a whole don't at me
breaking down that situation so you
should definitely check it out if you
want to know more this by the way is the
vac band account now there's not a lot
of information on it but just look at
some of the past names mad hacker leet
mad cuz bad why you bad
get rekt get rekt mate suka blat blat
suka wait come on
that's not a cheater account I don't
know what is now like I mentioned
earlier it took face at a hot second to
catch these two they note that a
technical issue from a previous patch
caused the anti cheat system to not work
properly for multiple days then
according to their statement an update
released on Wednesday managed to fix the
system which was naturally when the
system caught these two idiots if you're
not aware faces a third-party system
that gives players premium servers to
play on and has a better anti cheat
system than you'll find in csgo
matchmaking and because regular csgo
matchmaking has such a rampant cheating
problem face it offers a better although
not perfect alternative and get this
according to face its statement once the
anti cheat system got up and running
again
apparently 80 people were banned from
different tournaments across the
platform I'm just imagining some hacker
crashing the anti cheat system causing
this mad free-for-all and face it it's
just scrambling to fix it hurry
ossification
now the outcome of all of this is
because wolves and Jays a have been
disqualified runner ups from Team
enhanced will be moving on in their
place now in the last few months it
feels like cheating is all anyone in FBS
eSports wants to talk about hell
we made three separate don't appease
talking about how bad cheating has
gotten and games like Rainbow six siege
valor n' and even overwatch I bet you
think your game is full of cheaters lord
knows I've complained about csgo
matchmaking enough times but it's
nothing compared to the hacking problem
that overwatch seems to have it looks
like an AI almost but I think it's a
human I don't know what to be honest at
this point so just like completely hard
locking and because cheating is such a
hot topic the conversation around anti
cheat systems like face it or valor ins
Vanguard have picked up and have a lot
of people concluding that hey maybe it's
worth using these intrusive systems if
it stops cheating I promise [ __ ] is if
any company is not being intrusive with
their anti cheat
they're not gonna detect any cheats like
that's just that's just a reality of it
like Blizzard really respects privacy
and they're being really stubborn about
it and I can understand that but cheats
are gonna become more intrusive and more
intrusive it's not going to stop at all
it's kind of staggering honestly face
its anti cheat system being down for
four days just highlights how useful it
is I mean 80 goddamn people got caught
the day it was working again if that's
not a great advertisement for why csgo
and other eSports need systems like this
I don't know what is I'm just honestly
surprised I haven't been banned by some
sort of toxicity system well I mean
let's just let's be honest here I have
anger problems and they usually come out
whenever I end up playing csgo when I'm
not playing with Colin or Shehab or even
you Keith like somebody who I need to at
least be somewhat presentable around
dude it is [ __ ] bad like I am yelling
and swearing at my teammates yet